it's midweek training for the 12 to 17
year old girls of actonians LFC in West
London they've got the passion here
they're developing their talent
but football clubs like this are under
pressure as running costs saw if it
carries on the theorists that we have to
decrease our our training hours and the
space that we can afford to to rent
which in turn will affect the the level
of the coaching and the development of
the players
club's not alone 9 out of ten Community
sport groups said they were concerned
about the impact of increased costs in a
recent survey
but after the lionesses victory at the
Euros last summer this should be the
ideal time to harness enthusiasm for the
game amongst girls
there's huge momentum in women's
football at the moment with the FA Cup
Final between Manchester United and
Chelsea here at Wembley a sellout that's
90 000 tickets sold which is close to
double the previous attendance record
but there's a real danger that young
talents with the potential to rise
through the ranks could be lost to the
game if Grassroots clubs go under
because they simply can't afford to pay
the bills
and clubs are reluctant to pass on the
extra cost of energy facilities and
insurance to parents
Pharaoh Williams and Katie Chapman are
former professional footballers and go
into schools to encourage girls to play
I think football is now turning into
what I would say is probably a more
middle class sport which certainly
wasn't when I was growing up and I think
that's the difficulty I think people are
struggling to to pay and fund the sport
so I think there certainly needs to be
some funding into that to allow access
for all and if we want our game to
really grow and develop the way it
should
there's clearly a great deal at stake
for these players
Connie's just really important because
this club means a lot to a lot of people
places like this are definitely
important especially in communities
where there's people from everywhere
just brings everyone together I'd be
quite devastated because this is mainly
what I do this is like my main
um the thing that I do that I enjoy the
most
recently promised equal access to
football in schools for boys and girls
backed by a multi-million pound
investment
but for community-based clubs times are
tough
Emma birchley Sky News